I like to think that as the world's first
robot lawyer,
DoNotPay will have succeeded  if the word 'lawyer'
is completely removed from the dictionary
for average people.
Joshua Browder is trying to upend the legal
services industry.
His company, DoNotPay, has built an AI-powered
chatbot
that interviews users about their legal problems
in plain English,
then uses their answers to complete and submit
legal paperwork on their behalf.
The 21-year-old entrepreneur from the UK,
who taught himself to code with YouTube videos,
lives and works with his 8-person team out
of the same Palo Alto house
that Mark Zuckerberg rented during his first
summer in California building Facebook.
DoNotPay initially focused on fighting parking
tickets,
and Browder says it’s succeeded about half
the time,
saving users $16 million in fines over its
first 3 years.
Now, operating on just over $1 million in
venture capital funding,
the company is extending its legal services
to a broad range of issues—all free of charge.
There are such fundamental issues where the
small bit of software can help millions of people.
People don't even know which court house to
go to, or what documents to file
and if you can just help with that, then you
can solve maybe half the problem.
You started with parking tickets, because
it's a sort of regressive tax on a lot of people
that makes the poorest among us pay the most.
And in a lot of these cases people don't even
know that they do have some recourse, right?
So how do you educate people and how can they
find out how you can help them.
So, for example, for parking tickets it actually
plays a game of 20 questions with you
to figure out a legally sound defense.
It will as you 'was the parking bay too small?'
or 'were the signs hard to read?'
So we're not expecting people to come in knowing
what they can do
just if they have any issue that bothers them,
come to DoNotPay
and we'll get you your money back.
DoNotPay’s app even monitors users’ accounts
and can automatically rebook plane tickets
when prices drop,
request refunds when banks charge illegal
overdraft fees,
and help users reclaim security deposits from
shady landlords.
The flagship feature is, if you have a problem
with anyone,
be it a corporation or your neighbor, you
can sue them by pressing a button.
What happens when people actually get to court
to contest these things?
So at that point we actually give you a script
which you can read yourself.
In the future I think robots will actually
be allowed in court.
But until that day comes, people actually
have to show up themselves.
But they can almost be a conduit for the robot.
What we give you is very legally sound
and you can actually play a game of almost
learning what you have to say
with the robot lawyer in the app.
Browder says the legal industry is so ripe
for disruption through software
because most services involve nothing more
than standardized processes and boilerplate language.
I'm very lucky, although I hate lawyers, we
actually have a few good ones who are helping us.
50 states with a bunch of different jurisdictions
within them
you cover that entire gamut of different legal
structures?
Yeah, at the end of the day lawyers like to
make it seem like the law is rocket science
but in reality, the law is society's operating
system
and the rules should just be able to be coded
without some fancy AI.
We have got a bit of it on top but really
it's just a rules based system.
Given that, why are legal services so expensive?
Right now, if you're a lawyer, there's no
incentive to innovate.
Instead you can just be making millions of
dollars a year
by charging clients huge amounts of money.
And so because lawyers control the legal system
and no one else really understands it, they've
kept it that way.
And I think it will take people outside of
the legal profession like software
to force them to change.
And what's your response to people that say,
you know, you're delving into things like
immigration,
this is not just a standardized parking ticket,
you only have a few lawyers helping you,
you can't possibly be providing the level
of service that a trained legal professional would.
I think we really have a long way to go, but
on the other hand,
if it really is that different for every person,
doesn't that mean it's unfair?
Do you also hope to sort of incentivize the
broader legal system
to become more simple and fair in this way?
Yes, and I think the only way to do that is
by doing a bottom up approach.
I like to think of it as DDoSing the legal
system to make it better.
One of the most exciting things we have coming
out
is something that can get you a DMV appointment
in a few days rather than months.
By phoning up the DMV hundreds of times a
day and talking to their automated scheduling system
to try and look for a cancellation for you.
So this sounds great on my end, sounds like
a nightmare from a bureaucrat's end,
or regulator or someone who works at the DMV.
Have you gotten any push back on any of these
initiatives?
We think hard about doing it in an ethical
way
so we're only talking to their robots, not
real human beings, holding up the phone lines.
And in fact a lot of governments welcome DoNotPay.
When DoNotPay Parking Tickets came to Los
Angeles
they said 'we love it' because people write
such gibberish in their appeals
that at least DoNotPay's appeals are standardized
and well written.
So I think that in the long run, the governments
will build their own systems
for dealing with all of this traffic
which will lead to a much fairer outcome for
everyone.
DoNotPay doesn’t charge for any of its legal
help.
This way the company can serve clients who
can’t afford to hire lawyers,
such as refugees seeking asylum and homeless
people applying for public housing in the UK.
The company is also working on a service that
helps navigate the US visa process.
All of these processes are so bureaucratic
that if you have no resources at all
it really is impossible to get the help you
need.
So DoNotPay is a completely free public service.
So how do you sustain yourself, how are you
making money?
Although we have to make money to sustain ourselves,
we're not going to be doing it by charging
for our legal services.
Maybe one day we will help so many people
for example fly airlines
that we will learn how to do an airline ourselves,
maybe DoNotPay airlines.
That's a big example but we plan to replace
the people we're fighting,
that's how we'll make money.
But I'm not focused on that for the moment
because everything's fully automated.
We're very cost efficient.
And there are other similar services
or at least ones that allow you to automatically
contest parking tickets
but they make money by taking the slice of
the revenue that they return to people.
Why didn't you adopt that sort of model?
50% of injustice is still injustice
and by profiting off the problems, these companies
actually have an incentive to perpetuate them.
Which is why they haven't been solved.
I think the biggest example are all these
tax filing services,
which are now lobbying the government to keep
tax filing complicated.
The government has tried to have a much simpler
tax filing process
but the companies, publicly listed companies
that make money off that sort of thing
are saying 'no we want it to stay complicated.'
So DoNotPay doesn't have any of the conflict
of interest.
But Browder does advocate for more consumer
protection laws.
DoNotPay never relies on corporate policies
to get customers money back on things like
airline tickets,
using only regulations buried in fine print.
The way we do it is through these obscure
Department of Transportation rules
that allow the most non refundable ticket
to become refundable.
And that's really important because laws are
hard to change.
Of course all these corporations have lobbyists
but it's much harder for them to repeal airline
protections
than it is for them to just change a customer
service policy overnight.
Do you feel that these consumer protections
are more necessary in the airline industry
or because, like you were saying earlier,
a lot of what you do is help people navigate
complexity
complexity usually ends up hurting the less
well off
because they're not able to fund actually
going through it, don't have the time.
So in other areas, where, like tax preparation,
it's better if it's more simplistic.
Why is the regulatory push in the airline
space a problem?
I'm from the UK and one of the biggest differences
I've noticed between the US and the UK
is that in the US it's the land of the corporation.
In the UK there are so many rights that everyone
has, for example,
if the airline changes your flight time, you
have a right to cancel.
I think that's a very reasonable right for
people to have.
And DoNotPay helps people exercise those rights.
So it's not about complexity, it's just about
giving people what they deserve
and what's just and fair.
So in the long run, how do you see DoNotPay
sort of expanding
what space do you see it occupying and what
do you think the future is of legal services
once everything can be automated, including
a robot lawyer coming with you to a courtroom.
In silicon valley companies like AirBnB and
Twitter
have succeeded by adding words to the dictionary.
You can tweet something or snap something.
I think DoNotPay will have succeeded
if the word 'lawyer' is completely removed
from the dictionary for average people.
There's a 200 billion dollar legal industry
at the moment
and DoNotPay will hopefully one day make it
free for everyone.